Drax reste ici avec Rocket, regarde-le,
c'est pour qui ils viennent Je veux
venir, pas de mantis, regarde le groupe Drax,
tu sais quoi faire avec ceux-ci,
appuie dessus, qu'est-ce que tu pousses, j'appuie
dessus, appuie sur le bouton,
on dirait  tu appuie sur le trou de la serrure, qu'est-ce qu'il y a
un bouton sous la
poignée,
appuie sur ça, d'
accord maintenant, qu'est-ce qui ouvre la porte,
c'est un design stupide et tes
instructions n'étaient pas claires, attends,
attends, vas-
y,
j'avais huit ans quand je suis parti de là,
tu veux  moi je conduis non je vais conduire
trouver comment le mettre en
vente à l'envers maintenant
nous sommes les Gardiens de la Galaxie tout
l'amour que tu ressens romantique sexuel non non
je ne le fais pas non
tous les rires non réessayez
comme indiqué  à cela, c'est triste,
tu sais ce qui est triste, les gens sur Terre meurent
quand ils ont 50 ans. es-tu sur le point de
mourir, je ne suis pas en sécurité à 50 ans,
alors que devrions-nous faire ensuite pour commencer ton
été, quelque chose de bon, quelque chose de mauvais avec
une fin heureuse,
frappe-le  de ce que tu as des problèmes,
oh, viens
dans les billets du volume trois du Galaxy
jusqu'à maintenant